potatoes are a staple food and there are
so many different ways to prepare them
we're going to show you the ultimate
version of four classic preparations
that you'll want to make over and over
again
the first recipe we're going to start
off with is roasted potatoes the perfect
roasted potatoes should be crispy on the
outside and creamy on the inside they're
easy to make but also really easy to get
wrong so let's go over a few tips to
make the ultimate roasted potatoes
when making roasted potatoes you want to
pick a waxy potato like a dutch baby red
potato or fingerling potato
waxy potatoes have low starch and high
moisture which means they can hold their
shape and are ideal for things like
roasting potato salads and scallop
potatoes on the other hand starchy
potatoes have high starch and low
moisture which yields a fluffier
interior it makes them ideal for frying
and baking a few potatoes like yukon
gold's are actually considered both waxy
and starchy so they're super versatile
one easy trick for roasted potatoes is
to parboil them instead of just roasting
them all the way through
add your potatoes to boil in water and
let those boil for five to seven minutes
this step saves time helps them cook
more evenly and even makes your potatoes
crispier after roasting them
after that's done you can either leave
them whole or chop them we're going to
quarter these so they're more bite-sized
[Music]
you can get pretty creative with your
seasoning but we're going to keep it
classic and add olive oil salt pepper
and rosemary
whatever you do don't skimp on your
seasonings if you under season these
they can be really bland
[Music]
one crucial tip to know is to not
overcrowd your pan if your pan is
overcrowded and your potatoes are too
close together the moisture will end up
steaming them and your potatoes will be
mushy
you want to roast these at 400 degrees
for 35 to 45 minutes depending on the
size of your potatoes halfway through
roasting give your potatoes a stir to
keep them from sticking to the pan and
make sure they cook evenly
when these are done they should be
browned on the outside and fork tender
on the inside roasted potatoes can seem
kind of boring but when they're done
right they're actually really delicious
seriously they can be even better than
fries
everyone has their favorite style of
mashed potatoes for this recipe we
wanted to create the ultimate creamy
mashed potatoes
we're using yukon gold potatoes they're
harder to over mash and have a foolproof
creamy texture something like a russet
potato can get too gummy if they're over
mashed we're gonna peel the potatoes
before boiling some people like leaving
the skin on in their mashed potatoes but
for really creamy potatoes with a
uniform texture it's gonna work better
with the skin off quick tip to keep your
potatoes from discoloring and oxidizing
as they sit out place them in a bowl of
cold water while you work
after you've peeled potatoes cut them
into 1 inch pieces
that way they'll cook more quickly
then cover them with cold water and
bring to a boil for about 12 minutes
while your potatoes are boiling you want
to add milk cream and garlic to a small
pot and bring that to a simmer
that way the cream will still be warm
when we add it to the potatoes later
infusing the cream with garlic is
optional but adds a lot of really great
flavor once it simmers just make sure to
strain that garlic out
for mashed potatoes most people use a
masher some people use a potato ricer
for a more uniform texture
but if you don't have that another trick
to get a similar result is use the fine
mesh sieve
push the potatoes through the sieve
making sure to scrape all the sides it's
a little extra effort but you'll get
much smoother potatoes than you would
with a masher once you finish this step
you want to work quickly while the
potatoes are still warm add in cold
butter and stir until that melts into
the potatoes the butter will coat the
potatoes so that they stay firm when we
add the cream
then gradually add the infused cream
once the potatoes are smooth add your
seasoning again don't be shy potatoes
are great but they need a good amount of
seasoning
and that's it this recipe may seem
really indulgent but you need a lot of
fat and flavor to get that classic
mashed potato taste
everyone knows how to make baked potato
to take them to the next level we're
going to show you how to make a twice
baked loaded potato
for these you want to use your standard
russet potato because they're ideal for
baking first brush these with oil then
prick the top of the potato with a fork
if you don't there's a small chance it
could explode in your oven
this also lets excess moisture escape so
that the potatoes will be fluffier on
the inside then bake the potatoes at 400
degrees for an hour once that's done
we're going to slice these in half and
scoop out the insides
just make sure you leave enough so that
you still have a sturdy potato skin to
hold the filling we're going to make a
classic loaded potato by mixing this
with sour cream melted butter salt
pepper cheese and scallions
[Music]
then we're going to scoop that back into
the potato skins and bake it for 10
minutes
then if you want to get even more cheesy
top it with more cheese and let that
melt in the oven for five minutes
[Music]
these are best when served with a
generous dollop of sour cream some
scallions and crumbled bacon now that's
how you take a baked potato to the next
level
we've already talked about traditional
french fries in our how to fry video
but if you want a healthier option
that's also less messy and time
consuming here's a go-to baked sweet
potato fry recipe let's peel our
potatoes if you like skin on fries feel
free to skip this step this recipe works
both ways
to cut these into that classic french
fry shape cut off the ends of your
potatoes so your fries look more uniform
then slice the potato in half
put the flat side down to keep it more
stable then cut half inch slices
after you've done that you can cut the
slices into two to three fries
the important thing here is to make sure
that they're all a pretty uniform size
that way it'll cook evenly and you won't
end up with any burnt fries pro tip
soak your fries in water for at least an
hour this will help draw out any excess
starch which gives you crispier fries
it's worth taking the extra time to do
this step because it really makes a
difference with fake fries
after they're done soaking make sure you
pat them dry like really dry desert dry
seriously any excess moisture is just
going to make your fries limp oof
add your fries to a bowl and toss them
with cornstarch make sure you fully coat
them on all sides this is going to help
make them extra crispy then we can start
to add oil and season them we're using
grapeseed oil but you can use another
neutral oil like canola or sunflower
then we're going to add paprika for an
extra kick along with some garlic powder
and pepper
it's really important that you skip the
salt at this point you want to add it
after instead because if you add it
before baking it can draw out the
moisture and keep your fries from
getting crispy we'll add plenty later
with most baked recipes at tasty we use
parchment paper but from testing this
recipe using foil actually gives us
crispier fries you also want to make
sure the foil is greased so you can
easily remove and flip the fries you
want to keep these pretty spread out so
that they crisp up and don't just steam
and get mushy in the oven we're going to
bake these at 425 degrees for 15 minutes
then give them a quick stir so that they
cook evenly and bake for another 15
minutes
make sure to keep an eye on these
and now's the time to add the salt and
again don't be scared to be generous you
want to do this pretty soon after they
come out of the oven to make sure that
the salt sticks to the fries
and that's it let's be real these are
never going to be just like fried french
fries but you can still get pretty
crispy baked fries if you follow these
tips
potatoes can seem like a boring side
dish but there's lots of ways you can
transform them and add extra flavor if
you follow these tips your potatoes can
be next level good seriously they may
steal the show
[Music]
um i mean i would make those roast
potatoes
right now or i would just like swim in a
bath of those creamy mashed potatoes
they were so good
just bathing them
[Music]
you